this week in our school matter series we
are focusing on the price of college
admission getting accepted into a dream
school based on academic excellence
requires a lot of dedication hard work
and sacrifice - and only a small number
of students it seems are willing to
endure that we met for students at
Miami's G Holmes Braddock senior high
school they shared the challenges of
reaching the highest levels of higher
education
applying to a college everything that
you do from basically eighth grade until
senior year is just leading up to like
that moment they expected to have a
perfect GPA they expected to be
president like of every club there is in
school we're still kind of trying to
understand who we are but then the
schools won't want answers now I feel a
lot of pressure in the terms of how many
things I have to participate in and be a
part of National Society then we have a
science National Society then I got into
national social studies Honor Society
also known as broke Kappa I started
freshman year doing Future Business
Leaders of America fu Lai then I'm in
math Honor Society which is Mu Alpha
Theta I also volunteer for a hospital in
Nicholas Children's Hospital
I'm on a free time I have very limited
so I would say in the day I have one
hour to thirty minutes of free time and
that time includes eating food and also
taking quick little naps here and there
you've got a lunch which is the only bit
thirty minutes every day usually because
that's when you see all your friends
it's not easy to find a balance
sometimes but you make do overtime this
definitely intrudes on the fact that I'm
16 and I should be having fun and going
on with my friends I want to do all
these things I haven't gone to the beach
in four years and I live in Miami the
biggest fear is like disappointing my
peers around me because if I make it
into college what will society think of
me I would be that kind of an outcast in
a way it definitely feels worth it
because I'm looking at the long term
I'll be stressing out till later
be relaxed and have fun and to be able
to experience a good life later what I
know is that you need to be true to
yourself you need to have integrity you
need to have confidence in who you are
and wherever you're going to end up
you're going to do great no matter what
psychologist Lisa d'amour is a CBS News
contributor and an expert in child
development she's the author of a new
book called under pressure confronting
the epidemic of stress and anxiety in
girls Lisa good morning we just heard
all those students talk about a lot of
the pressures that they had but the same
time they seem to put it in perspective
that working hard now will pay off later
what's good stress versus bad stress
well so it is true that working hard
does expand capacities you know high
schoolers gain tremendous intellectual
strength chromatic tremendous capability
over the course of high school we do
want to be careful about the assumption
though that going to a good college
means that you're going to have a good
adult life we don't actually have those
data when we look at adult well-being it
turns out that economic success
professional success are not that
strongly correlated with being a happy
adult instead the things that really
matter in adulthood are having good
relationships doing work you find
meaningful and feeling that you're
gaining skills so we want to try to keep
that balance in there about really what
the long-term targets on what do you
hear these students saying and the
students that you talk to well so what I
hear them saying and the kids that I
take care of too one of the things I
hear in this kind of pretty you know
intense admissions climate is that
teenagers will say to me you can have a
social life you can get sleep or you can
get your schoolwork done but you can't
have all three mmm and that to me
doesn't seem like what we want for our
high schoolers so what's the role for
parents and all of this obviously they
want their kids to get into good schools
they're the ones who are disciplining
them and telling them to go do their
homework and prepare for admissions and
essays but on the other hand they don't
want to see them too stressed right so
parents are sort of caught in the
crossfire here because the college
admissions situation has created a lot
of pressure the bar is very high of
course parents are gonna want their
child to have every opportunity
available and yet in the day to day
they're watching a kid who's not getting
enough sleep who's feeling pretty
stressed so there's two things parents
can do one again is to kind of keep
their eye on the long term target to
really be mindful that going to Harvard
doesn't mean you're gonna have a good
life right in fact you could go to
Harvard it'd be quite miserable later in
life or you can go to a school that
isn't a neighbor in college and go on to
live a very fulfilled life to sort of
keep putting that idea forward the other
thing I want
parents to do is to not confuse college
admission with college readiness those
are two very different things to being a
college admission is really about your
academic credentials readiness is can
you maintain relationships do you know
how to take care of yourself are you
sufficiently mature to handle the
independence of college and I worry that
sometimes with so much stress on the
academics it's easy to lose sight of
other aspects of growth that are really
necessary for college success we've been
on that what are some of those aspects
of growth and maturity for me the main
question is whether or not a young
person sees their self-care as their
responsibilities so interesting yeah and
not something should say that again the
main question is whether they see their
self-care as their responsibility and
explain what self-care and self-care
getting themselves to that on time
getting themselves out of bed if arching
their clothes
why should never close if they're going
to parties managing their own safety not
equating you know am I going to get
caught with good decision-making don't
worry about getting caught worried about
could you get hurt right that's the kind
of thinking I want it's so interesting
because you're right we're concentrated
on getting them into schools instead of
building them as as independent future
adults yes how can we foster
independence in themselves and what I
will say is I think the kids are
actually stuck in the middle too because
the academic expectations are so high
that high school can tip into something
where all they're doing is homework and
there's not time to build out these
other assets where do we get the thing
that because shouldn't you encourage
your kids to work hard to get into a
good school at what point does it take a
turn that this is not the right way to
go I think you know it's one of those
things that you're in the weeds as a
parent and it's very hard to not kind of
get lost in this but what we want to be
mindful of is are we raising good
college applicants or are we raising
whole people and our job as parents is
actually to raise whole people who can
maintain relationships take care of
themselves and also do work yeah
important to find a school that's right
for you it's more about fit than about
brand I could talk to you for half
in the meantime people fabulous but
right I have read and has lots of good
information both people have sons and
daughters it's really good under
pressure thank you Lisa
you're welcome